Charles Dickens is one of the best-known
writers in the world and is considered
to be the greatest novelist of the
Victorian era if you live in an
english-speaking country you've probably
read great expectations Oliver Twist and
the Christmas carol in school his work
became so popular it even sparked the
creation of the word Dickensian to
describe his style so why is Charles
Dickens's work considered to be so good
that it has inspired future generations
and who was the man who created all of
these well-known characters well in
today's by graphics you're gonna find
out not a big surprise Charles Dickens
was born on the 7th of February 1812 in
Portsmouth England to John and Elizabeth
Dickens he was one of just eight
children and two of his siblings died at
a very young age throughout his
childhood young Charles loved to play
outside and he read as many books as he
possibly could his father John Dickens
was a clerk in the Navy Pay Office which
meant that he guarded money in a safe
and and to don't pay checks to sailors
the Navy would often move him from place
to place whenever it was necessary
though I was a boy Charles was able to
live in several different areas in
England John Dickens he was a very
ambitious man and hoped to climb the
ranks at his job eventually he was able
to move the family to London and pay for
Charles to get a private education once
he was living in the big city Charles
was exposed to performances from the
local theatre and he became inspired by
the actors and would jump up on the
tables of the local pub and sing and
dance he also performed plays with his
siblings and imagined that he would grow
up to become an actor his father John
was optimistic and did not prescribe to
the old-fashioned notion that people are
born in the place where they are
supposed to stay throughout their lives
he taught all of his children that they
could be rich if they worked hard enough
one day while walking with Charles he
pointed to a mansion called gadshill
Place saying that if he worked hard he
could own a house like that someday even
though John Dickens was a hard worker
and an excellent father he made the
mistake of spending his money before he
could really make it with so many
children and a wife to take care of the
often lived beyond his means his father
struggled
so much with money that Charles Dickens
had to leave school to work in a
blacking polish Factory at just 12 years
old yet the tedious task of giving
labels two bottles for 11 hours a day
making only six shillings per week even
though today would be like this is
totally child labor back in the day
totally cool
Charles was actually lucky to have found
that job though because his father ended
up in debtors prison Charles owed 40
pounds and six shillings and the only
way that he could get out of jail was to
pay back that debt but obviously if he
was not allowed to work or earn money in
prison he would never be released the
entire Dickens family had to move into
the prison with him even the young
children because there was nowhere else
for them to live since 12 year old
Charles is the only one who actually had
a job he could afford to rent a room
that was just big enough for himself and
the responsibility of freeing his entire
family it then fell on his small
shoulders
Charles visited his family every Sunday
and helped them in any way that he could
however since he only made six shillings
per week there was not much that the
poor boy could do fortunately John
Dickens was able to inherit some money
from his mother and he paid off his debt
in full even though he had to endure
this lifestyle for a year and he was
eventually able to return to school this
deeply affected Charles Dickens for the
rest of his life they had been fortunate
enough to receive the inheritance to
save the family just in time but what
about the people who are not so lucky
Charles realized that even well-to-do
families that were full of good people
like his they could fall on hard times
years later this would inspire stories
like Oliver Twist and Little Dorrit a 15
years old
Charles became a junior law clerk for an
attorney and he began to learn to write
shorthand while he worked at the firm he
would pay attention to the clients who
were coming in and looking for legal
advice he often wrote down their
physical descriptions and mannerisms and
wrote stories about them Charles had a
knack for finding humor and even the
most awful of situations in which often
laugh at some of the issues that people
were complaining about this it was just
the beginning of his fascination with
true crime as well as his ability to
write about difficult topics with a bit
of a sense of humor now that he was
growing up and had more experience in
the workforce Charles Dickens tried to
go after his dream of becoming an actor
when he was 20 years old he had an
audition for a play in Covent Garden but
he came down with a terrible cold and
had to miss his appointment he was never
given another
now at the time this must have seemed
like a horrible setback because this has
been his lifelong dream but if he had
become an actor he would have never
fulfilled his destiny of becoming a
great writer he eventually moved on from
becoming a law clerk and became a
journalist of the morning Chronicle even
at the paper he was still interested in
Lauren's not through court cases at the
House of Commons do report on what
happens this is actually where he met
the daughter of his editor Catherine
Hogarth after only knowing one another
for three months Charles proposed and
they were married in 1836 they were gone
to have ten children throughout the
course of their marriage
through his writing Charles Dickens
paints the Victorian era as the time
that was dirty dark and crude especially
for those who were living in the
lower-class well some of his social
commentary is very critical it's clear
that he truly did love England and he
wanted it to be better he felt the best
way that he could help was to write
stories that put a spotlight on social
and political issues it wasn't all dark
of course Dickens also wrecked touching
scenes where people could enjoy the
simple things in life like a warm fire a
good story and spending time with family
in fact his story Acrisius Carroll is
credited for capturing all of England's
best holiday traditions and that still
warms people's hearts to this very day
in all of his stories there was always
an underlying moral lesson and one of
the first issues he decided to tackle
was the treatment of the poor the
beginning of the Victorian era
was the height of the Industrial
Revolution and it was now more necessary
than ever to get cheap labour into
factories if the country wanted to move
forward with its economic progress when
Charles was 22 years old the 1834 Poor
Law made it a rule that if anyone was
living on the street they were taken to
live in a workhouse children were
educated while the parents would work
several hours a day in exchange for food
and shelter this caused a huge amount of
debate because work houses were
essentially prisons just for poor people
once they entered a workhouse there was
simply no escape everyone knew that life
in the workhouse was awful but people in
the upper-class were taught that poverty
it was someone's own fault any harsh
treatment it was necessary because they
deserved it as someone who grew up
suffering through poverty Charles
Dickens knew that good hard-working
people could sometimes fall on hard
times and that doesn't mean that they
should be thrown in a workhouse it was
clear to him that the lawmakers from the
upper class were out of touch with
reality and totally lacked empathy for
people in the working class it became
his mission to change the hearts and the
minds of the people of England he knew
two very important things that set him
apart from other writers firstly no one
likes being lectured to second is that
his audience would never care about
anything unless it had something to do
with them so Dickens he had to figure
out a way to make a story entertaining
first and almost hide his moral lessons
within the context of the story he would
also incorporate people in the middle to
upper classes and show
even having a privileged birth does not
necessarily mean that you are immune to
hardship when he was 24 years old he
began publishing his stories in
serialized form these were the Pickwick
Papers which was a satire based on
real-life political corruption at first
the stories they were not so successful
and Dickens was only earning 14 pounds
per month but after the fourth issue was
published it became a huge hit and sales
of his cereal went from 400 to 40,000
copies per month the fact that his work
was serialized a few chapters at a time
rather than releasing a novel all at
once was actually a huge benefit in his
fans would speculate what was gonna
happen next just like someone would do
when they're watching a TV series in
modern times people were so excited to
talk about the stories to their friends
that it soon spread by word of mouth
soon the name Charles Dickens was being
mentioned all over London and he became
a bit of a celebrity writer at age 25
Dickens would publish his serialized
story called Oliver Twist which shows
what life was truly like for a child
living in the workhouse the main
character Oliver was born into a
well-to-do family and he had the
misfortune of getting lost and ending up
in the workhouse readers were able to
think what if this happened to me he was
sure to make the stories humorous and
easy for anyone to read or more people
began to have empathy for the poor and
understands that something needed to be
changed this was years before the
Internet of course so the only way
Charles Dickens could do his research
about the biggest social issues
throughout England was to act like a
reporter and travel to locations in
person when he heard that young boys
were being abused in orphanages
he took a 2-day carriage journey to
visit one so that he could have a
first-hand account of what was truly
going on this inspired his story
Nicholas Nickleby he also visited inside
insane asylums to witness the
mistreatment of people with mental
illnesses and often walked through some
of the worst parts of London so you
might now be thinking wait what's that
Charles Dickens just showed up watch
people who are being abused and never
did anything except write a book well
the thing is
Dickens never claims do you have all of
the solutions to the problems in society
and with his experience sitting as a
reporter in court he knew that changing
a law was a complicated ordeal all he
could do was simply observe and write
stories about the truth this alone was
enough for people to talk about the
issues and begin to have empathy
for the downtrodden everyone wanted
their country to be better in that way
there has perhaps been no other man
alive who has done so much for social
reform in the United Kingdom than
Charles Dickens
even though Charles Dickens was never
able to fulfill his childhood dream of
becoming a professional actor he decided
to try becoming a showman in 1842
Charles and his wife Catherine they
decided to travel to the United States
together say that he could give public
readings of his works at the time books
were one of the main forms of
entertainment so the idea of a favorite
author coming to town was like a rock
star going on tour
Dickens insisted that tickets should be
discounted for working-class people and
he spoke to sold-out theaters every time
people who witnessed his readings
describes how passionately he would read
in the voices of each of his characters
and that no other performance of his
works would ever rival the author in
1844 to 1845 he spent time living in
Italy and Switzerland doing public
speaking engagements and writing a few
more books by 1847 he had and a
substantial amount of money from his
tour and he was finally able to invest
some of that money into actually helping
people at the time there were very few
job opportunities and childcare options
for women their only option was to get
married and find a man who could take
care of them and if they fell on hard
times they had no choice but to come
fallen women or sex workers if they were
arrested many of these women were sent
to Magdalene hospitals yes like Mary
Magdalene from the Bible they were
constantly told they were an awful
person and they were punished harshly
for their sins the only other option for
an uneducated woman besides the life of
a sex worker would be to live in the
workhouse which was essentially going to
prison at least with sex work they
maintained some freedom Charles Dickens
knew that many of these women did not
deserve to be in this situation and many
would be able to turn their lives around
if only they were given a place to stay
and get their life together
he founded the home for homeless women
at Urania College the women who lived
here were taught skills that would get
them jobs and of course he would also
interview them to hear their life
stories and he was able to draw
inspiration from them for his future
works
in March of 1856 Dickens was 44 years
old when he learns that the mansion he
had dreamed of as a child
gadshill place was up for sale he
purchased the home for 1790 pounds at
the time he had let go of his childish
wonder of the place and thought that the
very least it might make a good
investment and he would rent it out but
once he saw it in person again he truly
loved the home and it reminded him of
what it inspired him to work so hard so
long ago he kept it as his country house
and it became a welcome escape from the
city it was around this time that
Charles Dickens was beginning to have a
bit of a crisis he was at the peak of
his career but no longer happy in his
marriage with Catherine and he spent
more time throwing large parties at gans
Hill place at the time divorce was
totally taboo especially for a public
figure it also given himself the
reputation of being a pinnacle of
morality and had to continue pretending
that everything was totally fine one of
these parties Dickens invited over the
cast of a local theatre as well as
celebrity friends like author Hans
Christian Andersen it was around this
time in his life when Dickens met a
young actress called Ellen Ternan he was
45 she was only 18
they began having an affair but he kept
their relationship as secret as to not
damage the reputations in 1858 Charles
became separated from his wife Catherine
they no longer lived together but it was
forced to stay legally married during
their separation Charles tried to get a
divorce by claiming that his wife was
mentally ill the word soon got out and
it caused a public scandal he wrote in
98 letters about his issues with his
wife and they were only recently
discovered when they were sold through
auction in 2014 this has caused a lot of
debate among scholars some say that
Dickens was lying about his wife's
mental state and was willing to have her
committed to an asylum just so that he
could be with Ellen Ternan others
believe that Catherine truly was sick
because this man who had so much love
and empathy for other people would never
send someone to an asylum if it wasn't
necessary Charles Dickens continued his
relationship with Ellen behind closed
doors and bought her a house just
outside of London so that he could go
visit her the two of them continued
their secret affair for 13 years they
had a child together but he died in
infancy and they would never go on to
have another on June the 9th 1865
Charles and Ellen Truong trained
together when they approached stable
Hurston fun aside here everybody I grew
up about 10 minutes from staple Hirst
the track
to being repaired and the conductor had
no idea that it was happening the
conductor hit the brakes but it was
already too late all of the first-class
carriages they fell into the river below
the one and only first-class car that
remained on the tracks
it held Charles Dickens and it dangled
over the edge the second-class carriage
is behind him were enough weight to hold
it on Charles jumped into the water to
try and help the survivors if he found
someone who was just barely clinging on
to life then he would hold them and tell
them to take a swig of brandy more than
one person died in his arms a total of
10 were killed in the accidents and many
others were seriously injured just as he
was helping bring the bodies out of the
water he suddenly remembered that the
manuscript for his latest book our
mutual friend was still inside of the
train car he risked his life to go
inside and retrieve it before it went
over the edge for the rest of Charles
Dickens's life he avoided travelling and
getting on a train
gave him extreme anxiety for years no
one knew about Charles Dickens a secret
relationship because Ellen Ternan had
burned most of their letters eventually
historians though they began to piece
together the evidence a movie about
Ellen turn-ins life and relationship to
Dickens was made in 2012 and was called
the Invisible Woman
[Music]
after the accident Dickens's health was
suffering in 1867 he was given the
opportunity to go on another speaking
tour in America they offered him 20,000
pounds after expenses this is nearly a
million pounds in today's money it was
still suffering from a lot of travel
anxiety and he potentially had PTSD but
Dickens felt that he could not say no to
that kind of money but when he returned
it was clear to everyone that his health
had seriously declined in 1870 Charles
Dickens had a stroke and he died
unexpectedly at his home at canceled
place he was 58 years old and had
believes that he would have lived much
longer life
Dickens worked up until the day he died
and the last novel that he had been
working on was called Edwin Drood which
involved a murder mystery he died before
revealing the ends which caused his fans
to debate for years over what the true
ending must have been when he died his
estate was worth 93 thousand pounds
which is close to four million pounds
today in his will he stated that he
wanted a very quiet and private funeral
in Rochester however this sparked a
debate because many people wanted to pay
their respect so his family decided to
allow him to be buried in Westminster
Abbey in the days following his death
crowds of people showed up to pay their
respects to his open casket there were
so many flowers laid on top of him that
no one could see him anymore
even though he has gone the legacy that
Charles Dickens left behind it will last
forever today's work is read and
analyzed in schools all over the world
Oliver Twist was made into a movie
called Oliver and there are dozens of
film adaptations of his stories every
December families all over the globe
revisit the stories of Bob Cratchit and
then as a Scrooge in A Christmas Carol
there is almost no proper way to end a
video about a man who's accomplished so
much but what if we read a few of his
own words he once said whatever I have
tried to do in life I have tried with
all my heart to do it well whatever I
have devoted myself to I have devoted
myself completely in great aims and in
small I've always thoroughly been in
earnest so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did you know
what to do smash that like button below
and don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos four times a week
Monday through Thursday so please do
subscribe and you'll find out all about
those but if you click the bell button
because that's how YouTube works and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]